the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Music]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here
doing it in the night pants studios i am
ryan sickler ryan sickler.com
ryan sickler on all social media the
honeydewpodcast.com is the website for
the show
please make sure you're subscribed to
the youtube channel we drop audio on
mondays
you got video on tuesdays all right if
you if you got to have more do
join the patreon community that place
it's wait until you hear some of the
[ __ ] stories that are coming out of
this goddamn thing i am telling you the
[ __ ] we're hearing
is unbelievable it's five bucks a month
that's the only
level there is and if you sign up for a
year you'll save on over a month of free
episodes all right
uh you know i record here at the santa
monica music center so if you need music
lessons you need musical instruments
this is the spot if you're looking for
online classes
go to santa monica music dot com slash
excuse me use the code honeydew and
they'll waive the registration fee
and give you a free lesson when you sign
up for a package all right uh if you're
new to the show what we do over here is
we highlight the low lights i always say
these are the stories behind the
storytellers today's storyteller here
for the first time
very excited to have him please welcome
steve bird oh
i apply for myself you should clap for
yourself thank you buddy thanks for
having me man listen i know we've been
trying to make this happen yeah there's
a pandemic it's been fun we made it
happen
thank you for being here you got it it's
long overdue yeah even though i'm
looking at the black and gold
i picked this out of my suitcase today i
was like i gotta wear the
the hat hurts from 1979. i was six years
old that still hurts
it's it's it's they're they're going
nowhere i know they're going nowhere
but um please before we get going
somewhere plug
everything dude everything you want yeah
i'm
not sure when well i don't know yeah
i'll be at the i'll be at the irvine
improv uh february 13th i know are you
doing the drive-in shows
is that what i'm doing yeah i'm doing a
i believe a driving show
have you done that yet i haven't done an
uh driving
show yet i've done some outdoor shows
i've been doing comedy clubs but not an
outdoor show
yet so i'm a little trepidatious on how
that'll go
have you done it no i've done one show
this entire [ __ ] pandemic and it's
killing me oh just one
one bro oh jesus dude i did my first one
was
right at the height when um george floyd
um and they you know cops and so
you're outdoor dude the first
the first time i go on stage this is
like peak
rioting all that [ __ ] going down and i
i'm in miami i'm on stage i talk to
a black couple and i'm talking to them
and i'm just like getting their
perspective on things and
getting the crowd worked up and i
literally the next guy i talk to i go uh
he's like a buff guy in a medium t-shirt
and i go so what do you do he's like i'm
a cop i'm like
oh [ __ ] off all things you just feel the
air leave the room i just looked at the
black people it's like i got this
and i walk over and i start talking to
him and in the back of my head i'm going
okay well i'm going to get these two to
do a shot together but i can't
watch the choice of words
but i slowly started massaging the
scenario
and they were literally at two ends and
towards the end of it i got them to do a
shot uh
tequila and it just set the tone for the
rest of the show
the crowd started clapping everybody's
in a great mood and it was one of those
things was like only through experience
i think could i have
threaded the needle on that i you know
10 years in 12 years in 15 years and
maybe i wouldn't have been able to pull
that off but
but uh i posted it online and billy
gardell saw it
and he he walked me through he walked me
through the uh
the bit and he goes now pause it here
now here's here's here's
the mark of a true pro and he's telling
me and and i was watching i was like
holy [ __ ] you could see me thinking
these things and it was really
kind of cool to see another like
seasoned vet
walk you through one of your sets and
say this is why i respect what you did
that's really kind of cool oh yeah which
i've never had before happened in my
life
that's awesome well what's the what's
your website your social media your
everything's steve burn live your movie
yeah the
film is called the opening act uh came
out
uh during pandemic just a few months ago
it's
84 fresh and rotten tomatoes 87
fresh with audiences and rotten tomatoes
so it's uh it's [ __ ] great
it's [ __ ] great it's a real
encapsulation of what it's like to
really
not only hit the road as a comic but
your first time ever on the road
yeah so you've been to a comic club
you've never been on the road and that's
what this film is about
and what it takes to to take those first
steps on that journey
that's great yeah good for you to do
that it's cool
now i ask everybody to come with stories
you brought a handful of stories and i
like jumping around like this too i like
i love the life stories but i like
jumping around so
the first one you said you wanted to
start with was a
about a how to involve the bar stool
yeah yeah so i was uh
and this goes into experience right and
i was
i was new to the new york comedy scene
maybe two years in
and i was so is that where you started
did you start in new york yeah started
in new york
so the seller was the first club i
passed at which is crazy
like looking back on it the second time
i was ever on stage i got a manager so
it was like
out of the gates i was i was like
working
at a especially like an elite level with
like geraldo and colin quinn and jim
norton and all and patrice and
and and burr at the time so it was like
i was really exposed to a lot of greats
early on and so i was so hungry and like
to me stand up was always like a girl
when you first start dating her like i
couldn't stop thinking about it and so
i go the comic strip to work on a new
bit which was probably
dog [ __ ] and it was my birthday and i
didn't want to go out and celebrate a
drink i just want to go up and go
go up on stage so i go the comic strip
it's toward the end of the night
there's maybe like there's maybe 10
people in the audience
and uh i go up and maybe two minutes in
this one table stands up and they start
debating the bill and they literally
look like the cast of jersey shore
it was like you know it was that kind of
audience so i go guys could you just
maybe take this outside
and and then they start calling me like
oh okay with jackie chan
wow and then they they start saying
these racial things to me
and i was like well thank god the
lincoln tunnel's open 24 hours you guys
can get back to hoboken
or whatever the [ __ ] you know like
parsippany or whatever i said there's
only 10 people in there they're like
the other people over here loving it i i
didn't have that table like
i didn't have the experience you know to
handle the situation
how was it mostly guys or is guys it was
it was dudes and then a girl
okay and now she's doing she's pivotal
to this
[Laughter]
so they're saying all this like kung fu
[ __ ] and stuff and i'm i'm just like
[ __ ]
and that that that fuse was lit right so
then this girl chimes and she's like why
don't you shut the [ __ ] up and do your
jokes
and i was like will somebody tell this
gun to shut the [ __ ] up
and i dropped that c-bomb like
like dr strangelove the bait doors open
and it goes down i'm riding the bomb
and i drop it and next thing i know this
dude picks up uh one of the guys picks
up a power stool that was along the back
wall
where they're sitting and this is like
this isn't like some ikea [ __ ] this is
yeah it's all this furniture that's been
at this comic strip since the
late early 70s it's like a hard steel
forged
he takes it and chucks it and it's just
like
and i don't have the time to really like
react so i just like turn around
and the thing cracks the back of my whoa
so all of a sudden i felt like someone
was pouring hot water
on my neck just blood gushing and i
remember big j
okason runs in he goes whoa whoa and he
he starts
pushing the guys back and holding them
and they called the cops and stuff
and i was like such a young [ __ ] i'm
like i'm like all right well give me the
mic i'm gonna finish my set and jay's
like
you're going to the hospital dude did
you go i mean were you down
you got up from that no it it just like
hit you you got to be grabbing your head
and seeing blood on your hands
i saw a lot of blood and but i i i
didn't realize how bad it was until you
know they do he's like you got to go to
the hospital now so i went to the
hospital and i'm getting
eight staples in the back of my head
damn dude so chi chi
chi not stitches like the tank tank
and uh when they do it it really is like
that you know did you ever have staples
did you have okay
i'm not a couple right here yeah okay
yeah so it's like it's like like your
dad's putting some [ __ ] up in the garage
like yeah oh that's real like you're
literally stapling my [ __ ] head i
thought it was like a medical term like
flying goddamn what are you doing
[Laughter]
oh my god dude that was that early in
comedy like that huh
knock on wood all these years i've been
in i've seen videos online i've never
i've we i was at a show one time was in
irvine it was like me
larson fultron somebody else oh that's a
good crew to have your
back too that's a good crew to have your
back in case [ __ ] goes down i know i'm
it's me again
yeah exactly um but a lady rushed the
stage on jay she
charged and it was just weird it was it
was like being in a zoo and all of a
sudden that the door flew open you know
what i mean you're like huh
i know it's a lady but jesus christ what
he did yeah
i watched um i saw bill burr
at dangerfields there was a there was a
you know there's he's been known to push
some buttons
yeah a little bit there was a woman in
her 70s she was not [ __ ] having it
okay
and so she goes she says something to
him he's like later they didn't
just jokes it just jokes she goes no no
they're not
jokes and so she comes up but she's
walking it's like in slow motion because
she's so old
and bird just didn't know what to do so
he took the mic standing he held out he
goes
lady you can't do this you can't you
can't do this lady and i was like that's
so [ __ ] funny it's burning rj
you can't do this lady i watched um
well you'll remember back in the day
three clubs remember that little spot
three clubs oh yeah it was a great
little room and segura's in there one
night and i'm in there they used to do
like uh montreal call backs and [ __ ]
and i don't know what happened i'm sure
i'm gonna tell it a little bit wrong but
there was a lady who was belligerent the
whole time
right and tom finally called her a [ __ ]
right well i i think was her sons or
something were with her and they were
like
oh yeah we're gonna be stepping outside
so tom i've never really seen him
nervous because he's a big dude yeah
he's like
hey you mind coming outside with me call
that lady
i called that lady a gun and we had to
go outside he had to talk him down yeah
i remember and this is back in the dark
days which you're very
um aware of when nobody was coming and i
remember
i was getting called up on stage in the
or and right as i was
being called up this group of asian kids
was leaving the room
and in the like right in the middle kind
of back of this seating area
there's a guy eating chicken wings um
in the store he brought his own wings
he's sitting there with his boys
brought his own food and so he he looks
at me goes he sees the asians and he
sees me go up and say she goes
hey your friends are leaving and he does
this
with the wing sauce i go [ __ ] and the
fuse was lit i was like
i was like my friends left he goes yeah
your friends left i go maybe i'll go
outside and catch up with them he goes
maybe you should i go maybe you should
come outside and see them with me
he goes maybe i will and he takes
another bite of his wing and he goes
again i go well maybe we'll [ __ ] go
outside right now he goes
let's do that so you know how the room's
set up right it's like that
so i get off the stage and i walk
towards oh you're having this
conversation with him from the stage
i just got on stage i thought you were
just about to walk up yeah right there i
think jeff scott's still playing
he's still there so i
i walk towards the corner uh going
towards the
where the room ends and i'm going that
corner and he walks over and he starts
to meet me
and i just grab him and i throw i [ __ ]
everything i have in the
you know because i played hockey and i
just like you're used to just that
tussle first and i i just
get them on the ground and i start
wailing on them like ralph in a
christmas story beating the bully
and this guy he one of his friends takes
one of those
um the the tables and you know how heavy
those things are
again yeah comedy club foreign
he takes it and he's gone back brett
ernst
runs in and tackles the guy
that's right of course i could be eating
out of a straw right now
if it wasn't for brett earnest man he
would have that true skull with that
table
yeah those heavy bottom those lead bop
[ __ ] dude yeah
i'd have been [ __ ] damn man you got
into i mean i was asking if you better
than fights but you've been in enough
in comedy yeah
but i i again i think that comes with
the maturity of understanding you can
never
let any anybody in that room ever rankle
you because you've got to be in complete
control
even if like there's a some semblance of
like insecurity that'll bubble up
the audience reads it and they will you
will lose credibility in the room
immediately
as you know and so you know even when
when that [ __ ] thing happened and this
thing happened it's just like you've got
to be better than the situation
any situation so now you know years
on there's nothing that'll wrankle me
and it's almost like i'm dean martin on
stage where i'm a little more
cooler than the situation just like oh
you really think that
okay and then slowly you slide into the
arsenal of weapons
i got a pocketknife i got a chinese star
i got a gun if i need it i got all these
things we figured you had a chinese yeah
i got it exactly nowadays i could just
cough on somebody
but um but even are you okay
the way he laughed so hard at his own
joke he choked himself so if you
choked to death it would have been
because of your own [ __ ] joke i
laughed at the racism within
within the joke of those people being
absurd but even the cops when they
called me they said you want to press
charges i said no
because even at a young age i had the
wherewithal to say it's my this is my
lesson to learn
i i could press charges i could have
sued them i could but it was like
i [ __ ] up that was on me i shouldn't
have taken it to that level and i should
have never let someone
if i'm a professional comedian and if i
the aim is to be a headliner a headline
is going to be better than any situation
period and i wasn't at that time and
having foresight
young enough to have foresight i was
just like you can't do that
you're [ __ ] you're right i mean i
believe in exactly what you're saying
but i
there are times i daydream that someone
comes up on stage and i take that mic
cord and i wrap it around their
[ __ ] neck and i just
you know i do have that fantastic yeah
like when that guitar rack remember he
smashed it on the
person and then the audience turned him
he's like what it's like
no he's got it right it's every comic's
fantasy it's it's great
damn dude i didn't know you had that
kind of [ __ ] heat coming in comedy
yeah um what did you want to go into
next
you said you had a phoenix fight story
oh phoenix is that a comedy one this is
this is comedy plays into it okay
so i was in phoenix doing a young
mike young had this young comedian tour
okay it was like sebastian
and me and christian and whatever and so
we go out on the road
and i mean we're just young and dumb you
go out and it's just like a stumbling
plethora of dudes and booze and
i had met a girl with one of the other
comics we go back to the hotel we jump
in the pool
we're all hanging out eventually we
partition off i'm in a room with the
girl and
you know hang out and then and you know
it's time for her to go so
so i i walk her down to the other comics
room
and uh and the girls are
talking and me and the other comic are
talking and eventually
uh the girls just kind of leave and walk
out and i was like i'm gonna walk into
the car he goes oh okay yeah i'm gonna
stay here i was like okay
so as i walk out now in the lobby it's
probably been two minutes since they
left
um i'm walking in the in the lobby
and they parked in the parking garage
below and
i see this black guy and
this is relevant to the store okay so i
would normally say just a guy but he's a
black guy he's holding the doors open to
the elevator and there's four guys
behind him so it's like
it's like new additions there okay and i
crawl under
crawl under
i go under his arm i go in his arm
and he's hitting on the girl ducked
under his arm i duck under his arm out
of my
gents i totally get it but uh i'm just
walking to the girls the car and
i i i'm patrick swayze and ghost i do
not exist he doesn't even
pay attention to me he's like he's like
come on girl let's just hang she's like
i'm not hanging out with you it's like
come on come on
give me your number at least give me a
number she's like i'm not giving her my
number he's like you want you want to
hang him with his bling you want to hang
this bling he's holding him through the
neck and she's like i don't want to hang
with you playing and i'm
even his buddies like tapping on the
shoulder like come on whatever let's go
this goes on for what seems to be at
least like five minutes it's non-stop
the elevator's
and he's holding it the boys i'm just
sitting there i'm like [ __ ]
and and then she says he's like come on
come on girl let's just hang give me a
number give me a name
she goes i'm not giving you my number
you and then she drops the end
no yes and
she says the n word and now all of a
sudden it's just like oh god
oh god he walks in the other and there's
four black eyes there's four black guys
four five together okay he walks into
the elevator
[Laughter]
johnny just rolled up
he walks in and he starts walking
towards the girl and i get in front of
him
and he grabs me and i grab him again i
played hockey
i know you grab the jersey so i grab his
shirt and i pull it over his head
and i'm going for broke i'm like we're
in an elevator
and i'm just wailing on him as hard as i
can to just
end this situation so he drops to his
knees
and i'm hitting and i'm just going i'm
just drilling i'm drilling as hard as i
can and he goes
chill dog chill i go what he goes chill
dog chill i go you done
he goes chill dog chill i go are you
[ __ ] done he goes i'm done i'm done
now in this moment i realize
the elevator is stopped we're not moving
at all because when we grabbed each
other we
knocked it off its moorings so we are
stuck between
the lobby and the parking garage the
girls are crying
i remember sarah smiles by holland
oates's plane
in the elevator
every time i'm in a cvs or walgreens and
i'm waiting to pan i hear that song
i'm in an elevator in phoenix okay so
now this guy
so it's you two girls and four or five
of us
no just the one guy okay they're still
out there okay
so now he gets up and
he takes he pulls his shirt over his
head the song's playing the girl's
crying
nobody's talking okay and he's pulling
his shirt over and he's just staring at
me
he's staring at me and i go he's gonna
[ __ ] he's gonna come at me he's gonna
hit me so get ready get ready
and he's staring at me and i start
staring back at him and he's looking at
me
and he kind of squints his eyes and he
goes uh
hey man were you uh are you on bt's
comic view i go
yeah he goes you do the bruce lee bit i
go yeah he goes i
love that joke
i was like [ __ ] yes you just kind of did
that [ __ ] on me here in the elevator
and so he goes he goes what are you
doing here i go i was just at the improv
where i met this [ __ ] racist
so i didn't know that and so now he and
i are talking
the girl's crying and then all of a
sudden here
[Music]
and the elevator goes back to the lobby
so i guess the uh
general manager came over and did some
key whatever the elevator door is open
his boys are waiting there they heard
everything his boys come in
pop pop pop ting ting shirt ripped
they rip my shirt punch me here punch me
i got a black
it starts to swell up they cut my lip he
goes no no no no
guys guys guys you know who he is and he
go oh he goes
remember a comic view he does the bruce
lee bit they go oh [ __ ]
he goes yeah and i'm like i'm like i'm
like oh my god i'm safe
and uh i'm like yeah i'll get you guys
tickets if you want to come to show us
you know doing this [ __ ] i'm like okay
and then and then the manager
in the lobby goes the manager goes i
called the cops they're on their way
they [ __ ] bolt the girls in the
elevator it goes back down
i'm standing there by myself in the
lobby shirt ripped
bleeding eyes starting to puff up and
i'm not saying who the comic is but
you'll be able to figure this out
literally dressed in all adidas walks
out of the business center with a
cappuccino
holding with two fingers and he just
looks at me goes
what the [ __ ] happened to you guys
and uh that's that's the end of that
story
that's my greatest fight that i've ever
been in
and look i mean how do you top that
beating the guy and then he recognizes
yeah in the middle of it
i've been on the ass end of fights but
that was my last that was my last fight
that was my last
fist fight yeah it was uh yeah you can't
be still especially in the 30s and 40s
yeah i mean if you're still actively
fist fighting in your 40s
you're really you really got problems
you got it like no let's go [ __ ] them up
like that's
a psychiatrist
[Music]
[Laughter]
i realized i was out of shape for fights
when i had kids that had to start
chasing them when they were toddlers and
running like oh
yeah you just wrestle with them you like
guests and you know how fights go like
it only lasts
it's it's not long never it's never long
it's no they live
scene with roddy piper and keith david
it's [ __ ] a few minutes
everybody's out of breath everyone's
tired [ __ ] like you done
i'm good
i could take more of this but my
[Laughter]
there is that mutual respect now i think
as you get older if you're in bars and
stuff and somebody gets slippy whatever
i think
now at our age you see a little sprinkle
of a gray in there you're like
guys do we let's just get a beer let's
just get a beer let's have a drink
i've had a few of those where the
situation has been diffused via another
friend or whatever it's like
let me just buy us around guys let's
just do that and i think everybody knows
it's like
yeah let's just do that well you come
from pittsburgh
i'm baltimore towns like philly like
they're
they're blue collar yeah spell
towns and you're gonna get in fights
they're angry [ __ ] cities
yeah chips on their shoulders oh yeah
and people bad diets and
yeah everything and diet bad childhood
chips on your shoulder
yeah um what would you like to share
next uh well but um
well i guess we could talk about uh yeah
i mean you know comedy has provided me
with so many lessons
and in terms of you know how i handle
myself and my everyday life and how
you take lessons from the stage and you
know there was it's period of time where
i was uh
i was a new york city comic and i'd go
in and out
and i'd i was making money on the road
but i like going on the road because
you could spread your wings you could do
a half hour and also being
a young guy in my 20s was also like
you're
a big fish in a small pond so you're
going to like
deja vu in colombia missouri and those
clubs where you just like oh my god
there's
all these girls here and they just saw
you on stage and what a layup and let's
see what happens with the night and
living it up and i was in houston texas
i believe
the call the club at the time was called
spellbinders
um and this is before it became the
houston improv
before the houston improv moved to the
new new area and
uh again i was working on the road and i
i went out on the road with another
comic from new york city who was
headlining and i was featuring
and it was a gorgeous space and it was
brand new and it was like the first week
the club was open
so the staff is drinking with the
managers and the comics
they're tailgating after shows and stuff
and and
like thursday i'm meeting everybody and
then friday i'm i'm talking to this
bartender who was really pretty and
really cool
and we ended up hanging out that night
and you know getting something the next
day to eat and
and then saturday comes along and she
she uh we were drinking it was it was
just like friday was great
and then um the other comic was hanging
out with the waitress and i'm with the
bartender we ended up going back to the
comedy condo
and at the condo we had had quite a few
drinks to
take us in the evening and we were fine
then you know
and we come to find out that it was this
girl's birthday
and none of her friends had called her
and she was really
kind of upset by that and
and then she just wanted to leave we she
wanted to leave and we're like you're
not leaving
you're you're hammered you can't go
anywhere and she's crying and nobody
cares and all this stuff
so the other comic and i said look
let us go get um let us go get some food
so we go to the grocery store which is
like a block away and we walk over there
we walk back
and i bought her a birthday cake and
some candles and and
said hey let's celebrate your birthday
and that seemed to change the mood and
got some food and her were thinking okay
maybe she'll be okay she's still kind of
like a little out of it and stuff
and so i remember
she wanted to leave i hit her car keys
she found them i hit her shoes
she found them um i hit her purse she
found
it i was like doing everything i could
you might suck at hiding [ __ ]
sounds more like you're like i said i'm
over here i said it over here
that's that's probably true i was not
good at hiding it yeah
so so eventually i got to a point where
i was like
there's only so much a human can do
right before you tell somebody
you shouldn't do this and i was just
like i got to go to bed because i was
gassed i was tired and i've been there
you're trying to reason with a drunk
person
it's impossible it's impossible so i
remember going to bed that night
and i heard the other comic and the
waitress talking to her
and it sounded like everything was kind
of okay and i was like all right well
i guess i can go to bed so i i just
passed out right
and i woke up the next day
and the other comic woke me up
and said we gotta go to the comic club
uh the
the manager wants to talk to us i said
oh
okay so we go over which just so
everybody knows is not
[ __ ] never going yeah you're not
waking up if you're not doing morning
radio you're definitely not going to the
club
yeah they want nothing to do with you
until it's show time right
um so i go over with uh the other comic
and come to find out this girl had
driven driven home that night and got
into a car accident
and died died died um
and what the other comic had told me was
was the other girl in the car with her
no no she was by herself and basically
what happened was her birthday she died
her birthday
[ __ ] and the other comic had told me
that basically what they had worked out
is that she had convinced them
she wasn't going to drive home she just
wanted to get out of the condo she
wanted to be by herself and so the deal
was struck that
they were going to drive her to her car
and she's going to pass out and sleep in
the car
and then wake up and then drive herself
home
so they told me that they because the
the manager wanted to hear
everything that had occurred the night
before um
on behalf of the club and you know if we
did anything wrong or anything like that
so
so basically what had happened was
uh the other comic and the waitress
drove her to her car
they saw her lay down and it looked like
she was going to
fall asleep so they got back in the car
and as they got
on the road to go back to the condo
she gunned it past them and
they thought oh no that's not a good
sign you know um
so we got the the horrible news the next
day and then
did she hit anyone else or no i don't
know the exact details i just know that
she had
passed right she died so then
i had to perform that night and i was
scheduled to be there for two weeks
so i couldn't leave vegas this is in
houston texas
so i was there to feature for two weeks
to make enough money to make it
worthwhile
and at you know again i was young and
and i wish i had the wherewithal to just
say i should probably leave
but i stayed there and then it was
almost like i had a scarlet letter
branded on me because
i had been one of the last people to see
this person and there was an enormous
sense of guilt
thinking and rehashing everything that
occurred that evening
of you know what what else could i have
done
you know i i should have just stayed up
i should have like forced her to
to you could have been better at hiding
it could have been a better hiding like
it could have been a lot better at
hiding yeah you know you start thinking
of all those things you could have done
and then what happened in reality is
there's
nothing i mean short of holding that
person down
yeah there's nothing you can me and the
other comment disgusting what they want
to do
but this is the this is where it all
kind of came to a head was
where i had to talk to her mother
her mother wanted to know everything
that happened so her mom
called me and i told her
everything everything i just went into
detail throughout the whole
whole course the evening and not that i
needed solace
i i would hope that the mother would be
provided solace but the mother
said you know when she got her mind
fixated on something you could never
stop her she was very stubborn and that
to me
gave me uh a moment of like you know
like like
comfort and solace where i was like you
know it's nice that lady who just lost
her child
to be able to throw that your way yeah
and then before the show
that night her fr her best friend came
and
i had to sit down i you know i didn't
have to but i i said you're having to do
this [ __ ]
during the day this is your first show
before my day yeah
that is so my day could have been a lot
worse you know it could have been i
could have could not have had that day
could have been dead too
there's a thousand variables that could
have happened and and i talked to a
friend
and and and went into detail about
everything about about that occurred
once again
and you know she was at the my same
mindset telling me some of the similar
things about the
uh from the mom and obviously it was it
was really difficult to have
those conversations especially to a
mother but i will tell you that
early on in my career i learned the
dangers of being out after midnight
and that it comes with severe
consequences and i touch upon that
briefly in the opening act in the film
uh with levity via another experience
that really happened to me
but this one was too um
too painful and too dark you know there
was a an immense burden of guilt i i
carried with myself for
for years and to this day i still think
about it you know every now and then you
do not you tried to stop a person
yeah from killing themselves and
they did it anyway i mean that's yeah
yeah that'll [ __ ] with anyone and so i
pulled myself off the road after that
you did
i i said i will never go on the road and
i i i
i went to new york city and just i was a
full-time comic in new york and that was
it
and it wasn't until years later that you
know i moved to l.a and started kind of
like
i i i hit the road again as a headliner
um and i it had been i don't know how
many years it had been since i'd been
on the road uh as a comic but that was
that was it that was
the the moment in my life where i was
like all right there
there are consequences to your evenings
you know so
just bear that day job doesn't start
until
a lot of times eight sometimes you got a
10 o'clock show yeah at the midnight you
got the 11
you know you remember the old ontario
days seven nine and eleven on a saturday
you're not getting out of there until
after one yeah everybody wants to go do
something you gotta drive
back if you're featuring or opening you
know that's a hell of a drive
yeah exactly i remember i was dating a
girl at the time in comedy
and um she got a dui
and i started to i watched how it
affected her life it's not like you pay
10 grand and then you don't have a
[ __ ] dui on your right
you pay 10 grand the shit's there yeah
and public transportation to the aaa
meetings to the getting [ __ ]
signed to i just watched how it ate away
at her time
yeah and i thought well [ __ ] i'm here
back in the day at world cafe or
wherever we are i'm having
three or four beers i know i'm fine to
drive i know i'm fine to drive
right but if a kid runs out a dog
anything happens they're gonna say
well you have alcohol that test is not
designed for us to pass
right and i'm gonna be [ __ ] and that
was the that was like
the real shift where i really i mean i
still i smoke weed but i
i i if it's not a water or a diet coke
i might even have half a beer sure at a
club but that's it for me
and also sitting down talking to guys um
and girls that we know
who are like i can't just have one if i
put one to my lips i'm going 20. you
know i wish i could drink a half a beer
so i started to see like how it really
is you know a disease and addiction and
i was like man i'm fortunate
yeah so i try not to you know and these
days with
and i know that was early on these days
with uber and all that [ __ ] there's no
reason
yeah it's almost like you don't have an
excuse anymore to uh put yourself in
those situations but yeah
look i mean it comes with being young
and dumb right i mean
i was certainly young i was certainly
made some careless decisions i know for
a fact there are nights i've gone out
and
you know driven home when i shouldn't
have no doubt um and i thank god that
i look back on those days like jesus i
got it in my cell phone you know looking
down and right
all that other crazy [ __ ] you know so
yeah i mean
you know you it just seems like
everybody's got a lesson to learn
and you know for me my lesson
came with less of an expense than than
hers did and
it was certainly certainly it stuck with
me and i i went into uh
a depression i'd say for a good year
over it
i was pretty uh pretty tore up about it
um
and you take it out in different ways
but it it it definitely hurt but it
definitely
it definitely also helped me again
recalibrate
my perceptions on going out and
indulging
in the nightlife and not letting my ego
get too big
after any show no matter how big or how
great it was or whatever
so that was pretty brutal yeah that's a
tough lesson to learn
yeah and i was i recently moved into a
new home
and my parents from florida had sent me
a box full of old pictures and
you know programs when i was performing
and i uh
i was just going through all these
pictures i haven't seen since like you
know
15 20 years or whatever and one of the
pictures was
was me talking to her yeah when she was
behind the bar and she
you know just really really beautiful
girl and i'm
looking at her and i'm making a laugh in
that moment and i was just kind of like
wow it's
uh it just kind of retriggered yeah
everything and
again just um you know it is something
apparent
too and seeing it from that perspective
as well like yeah
i know bro it would kill me too but i
would want to talk to you
you know i don't want to ask what she
was like do you know all that stuff but
man
sure and and and again i i i'd known her
for 72 hours if that you know and
and what an what an impact that that
experience that
the you know that whole situation that
it had on my life and how it um
carried on with me so i had um
an eerily i'd say somewhat similar
experience
a friend of mine when we were living out
here early on
um had come out to visit and and he
brought a friend
this girl with him yeah who was then
going down to mexico from here to
like they came together and then they
were gonna split up here she was going
to mexico to surf with some friends okay
this beautiful young probably 22
23 just i can't tell you like you ever
meet those people where they're just so
pleasant and
sure you know they say the smile lit up
the room i'm i'm talking about like just
like this girl is like a sunbeam for
real sona i was like man you're a really
nice girl
you could tell well raised you know um
and the next day she's driving to mexico
so
she is in a car with
a guy up front and then there's four
other people in the car behind them they
couldn't fit them all in one car
and they're driving and they're in
mexico now and all of a sudden this car
comes at them on the other way and veers
at them
forces them off the road well they go
down a cliff they roll
crash and it's it's bad yeah and they're
laying there dying
and these locals come out and don't help
them and they rob them
they take their watches and their four
friends are watching this
and they realize after the police come
they both die
they die no jesus they realize after the
police come the police are telling them
look
sometimes this is a setup they'll have
that car could have swerved at them in
order to make them crash
and then they come over and they rob you
and and they
flipped and rolled and and we get the
news and i'm like
that girl that was just here 12 hours
ago that really nice sweet little girl
is gone and then her family has to go
figure out how to get her body out of
another country
and it's like all this [ __ ] and you're
like [ __ ] and i yeah i have never i
like you said i knew that i didn't even
know that girl she just stayed overnight
with us one night i met her
12 hours 20 hours i have never forgotten
that girl
and i just thought man what that's every
parent's
worst nightmare you're moving to
california oh my god please be careful
and she's not even there
a few days and she's gone okay in a
brutal ugly way
so i i yeah that one haunts me too i
think about that
often like god that poor [ __ ] girl
what yeah
and then to be robbed and when they
maybe they could have saved you you know
what i mean they're taking your watches
and phones and [ __ ] like come on
god damn yeah it's you know the um
you know i i think as you go on with
your life it's kind of like
thinking to your childhood you think of
all the times like
you know you jumped off that cliff or
you did this and you're just like my god
it's a miracle i'm still alive you know
given it's amazing any
of us make it past 17 18. all the
dumb [ __ ] yeah my god no helmets
no protective gear concussion after
concussion all of it
you know i it's yeah you're right it's
it's
um well but i learned that i'm not good
at hide and seek
i'm i'm bad at hiding [ __ ] yeah jesus
christ
um tell me about this reception story i
want to hear about this
oh the reception um well this is
you know i i think we all have a
perception
of how we view ourselves or especially
in the entertainment industry how we
may be viewed right and so i had a
sitcom called sullivan's son can i ask
you does
that live anywhere on hulu is there
anywhere right now where you can no you
can like buy it
on amazon okay but only the first two
seasons like the third season for some
reason shelved
um it never aired
but you just can't buy that one yeah
it's just another show that's
in the warner vault you know um
great experience one of the greatest
professional experiences i've ever had
in my life you had your own sitcom dude
it's the dream
it was the dream yeah i i think
especially great cast
comics of our generation that roy wood
and and yeah
no doubt what's the dad's name laurier's
dan yeah
yeah so brian dole murray was it was
great um
and so the show comes out and
it was you know i i know for a fact
we're the second asian american sitcom
to have ever been on the air that's
it what's the first one the first was
margaret cho's
all-american girl and then before that
there was a pilot shot for pat morita
okay a pilot shot for a comic named
johnny yoon who was a korean comic that
was uh that had a film called
uh they call me bruce back in the yeah i
remember they call me bruce yeah yeah
okay so he had that film
um so it's just a handful of
you know asterisks littered throughout
the
history of entertainment i'm thinking
this is kind of cool you know second
asian american sitcom
and it comes out and we get the
viewership
we're doing really well but never any
attention
or you know just it just kind of was on
for people that liked it which is the
way it should be right
but in this day and age of diversity
nobody ever gave a [ __ ]
about acknowledging like this feat that
it had occurred
and i was thinking i was kind of
important in you know for the community
and especially the asian oh yeah all
this stuff and i have to say
because it's always it seems like
whenever there's
someone of a certain community whether
you or
joe coy with the philippines or conor
mcgregor with ireland like i feel like
outside the u.s people back their people
hard
yeah they go hard for their [ __ ] right
yeah i i think
you know joe certainly
we're both mixed right and joe i believe
leans more into
his filipino roots i i'm more of a
centrist where a lot of my comedy too
explores the
identity issues that i might have in and
being tribeless
essentially but i think sometimes you
can stake a claim to a tribe and and be
very successful as
as joe has so you know the show comes
out
we're doing well three seasons all the
stuff i'm going in the third season
and there was an asian american blogger
and a prominent uh asian actor
uh there and where were they were on set
and then we go out to
we go to the comments here to have lunch
and i go i was just like this is crazy
like
they somebody called me to talk to me
about fresh off the boat
how it's the second asian american show
to come on the air since
all-american girl and i'm like you're
asking me to compliment the show
and saying they're the second but you
i'm the second
they're the third then so so i was kind
of like a little dismayed
at all the attention it was getting but
i also know it's abc and they get
they're putting all this money into it
and
they're making a thing out of it as
opposed to me and jody long and vivian
bang right
so i was a little miffed by it and i
brought it up to them
and i said it's just kind of kind of odd
that we're not getting
the support from the community and
and this uh blogger had said well it's
because you're not asian
i was like what he's like well asians
don't look you as asian
so you're not asian so you could think
that but and i was like
like i've been called the worst things
you could ever imagine throughout the
course of your life right black guys
thought you were [ __ ] asian
exactly right yeah everybody else is
jackie chan and everybody else thought
your age
and that's exactly the the the issue i
had with it right where i've been called
the worst things
by a thousand different people of all
different race and creeds and
and then finally i'm sitting down
inside warner brothers studio as i'm
about to walk to my sitcom
that i've done for two seasons and this
is the first episode of the third
and i'm so proud of everything and it
was like somebody
had held a mirror up to me and said you
never saw that mole on you i was like no
i never
and all of a sudden it just changed the
way i felt about myself about my
identity
it hurt you know it really really hurt
to hear someone prominent in the
tribe uh say that about me and all
almost like everything i'd ever thought
about myself was kind of like a
misconception
and it's almost like you know like
finding out your parents or
adopted you and it's like not your real
parents like what right so my identity
was kind of like
whoa holy [ __ ] that's really [ __ ]
crazy
but then well can i ask you why do you
think asians
or did he think asians didn't see you as
asian i think for the same reason
you know mariah carey will get guff from
like like whitney houston i saw this
documentary on whitney houston
and when she was as successful as she
was whatever i
she was getting like booed
at the i forget what what the awards
were for the black community at the time
but
but the black community was not
receptive of her they were not receiving
her
and so she went on to make more soulful
albums to kind of
you know i guess appease that that sect
of the audience
but you know i guess
there's always that that notion of like
you're not black enough you're not
asian enough you're not mexican enough
you're not american enough you're not
republican enough you're not democrat
enough right and then i just i
you know at that time it really did hurt
and it was very confusing but as time
went on i was like
well nobody's gonna [ __ ] define me
i'll be in charge of defining myself so
[ __ ] that
and so that was kind of like
i i guess a pivotal moment in my life
where i heard something
so profound and i took it in a negative
fashion
but i had to twist it and find the
daylight in that situation
and say okay well again you know are you
going to let
one person affect you because that's
their opinion it might be the opinion of
many other people but
the opinion the only opinion that
matters is what i think of myself and
how i view myself and i present myself
and
how i can what is the information
that i'm communicating on stage that i'm
parling to the audience that i want them
to receive
and so part of that is is now you know
developed into this new hour where you
know being korean and being irish it's
like
i don't i truly don't have a tribe when
all this blm [ __ ] was going down
i think that there were blm activists
reaching out
saying where's all the asians why aren't
you supporting
and i i didn't know that i had seen
they were here they were right outside
here they were out here and there's
orange
this one black comic had said where's
all the asians supporting blm
and then i went through and screen
capped
because i was on another feed seeing uh
my korean friends
like their storefronts destroyed so i
screen capped
as many as you can fit in one you know
mosaic
and i i tweeted back they're a little
too busy cleaning up after this mess
and you know i i think like even when
the blm stuff was
everything got tribal real quick you're
either white you're black
or you're a republican or a democrat
whose side are you on
and in that moment i went back to that
um conversation i had with that blogger
and i was like
my tribe is what i define it as and
my tribe is just being an american
that's truly what and i think if more
people stopped partitioning themselves
and looked at ourselves equally as
americans under the banner of the flag
i think we'd all get along a lot better
but that's not what's happening there's
niche entertainment
nothing's communal anymore that's why
ward shows are not successful
because there's no communal like we all
grew up with the goonies we all grew up
with
you know whatever the back to the future
nowadays that's that this new generation
is not going to have that
this geek culture is going to be so
partitioned and divided i think the only
communal thing
really that happens these days is sports
and news and that's [ __ ]
it yeah you're right so we're as
separated as as we ever will be
and i think it's going to continue to
happen unless perhaps
people like myself push the pendulum
back the other way and say
we're looking at this the wrong way we
got to look at this as like we're all
unified we're all here together
it's really you make a really great
point because but it's a voice of the
minority right now
i get [ __ ] on constantly for for saying
these things
if i post an american flag i lose
followers people [ __ ] on me but are they
are they mostly asian followers you're
losing when you do something like that
i'm really curious though do you know i
think it's across the spectrum
i post i am it is funny to me you're
right though like this last
four years yeah it's like if you wear
an american flag shirt you're you're a
trump supporter like they don't own the
flag
yeah they don't own the bible they don't
own guns i mean they own guns but they
don't own the second amendment
right you know like that's not theirs
like that's everybody's but you're right
it's it's like
well most whatever everything you're
right there's these different sects
and it's yeah we are so divided
here's what i want to know like it's a
great point like
so i can be discriminated my whole life
for being asian
but when it comes to finally being
recognized as asian you're all going to
tell me
you don't see me that way you're not
yeah that's a huge [ __ ] you what what
sort of uh racism have you do you
remember what's the first time you
remember
being treated differently well i was
especially racist
how probably six but you know when
you're a kid you don't know any better
but i was
born and raised you're always pittsburgh
right i was born in freehill new jersey
okay uh home of springsteen and i grew
up in
until i think i was 12. in jersey in
jersey and then i moved to pittsburgh
and that's where
like my formative years really happened
so i say pittsburgh but is there um
is there a large were there a lot was
there a large asian community
in either of the towns where you grew up
no i don't think pittsburgh like i
i'm no i'm thinking back to but
baltimore and i'm like i don't
[ __ ] even yeah yeah no i mean that's
you know your house is chinatown now
that's that's what that's what happens i
remember when i moved to pittsburgh
holly reed was the other asian of my the
other school yeah
at home at the first dance i ever went
to they're like you guys should dance
together
it's like what why because we're playing
you guys
you know you'd be asian together um but
yeah i mean i remember i was six
and some kid called me a [ __ ] and i i
laughed i thought that was like oh
that's a cool nickname and i wrote it on
my baseball glove uh
[ __ ] and my dad's like my dad's like no
he was uh
he was making fun of you and i was like
oh that's bad i i like i didn't
i didn't know and then my dad explained
it to me and i remember being six years
old
looking at my mom and just staring at
her like she doesn't look different to
me like she's just my mom
i was like is she different and i
remember going in the mirror
and i remember doing this i was going
like this to my eyes
at six years old and i was like they
don't feel different and it was just
like
it was weird to me i i didn't view
myself any differently but then as i got
into junior high school when i moved to
pittsburgh actually
um he ended up becoming a friend of mine
but this kid named i don't want to say
his name but john
john uh kept calling me a [ __ ] every
time i walked out and passed him in the
hallway chang chang chang i was on the
bus ching ching ching
and i was like i i was getting like
angry and my dad
i remember this is like the third day
now and i told my dad
just keeps calling me chick every time i
walk past him every time i do something
he goes well what are you gonna do about
it
you let him keep saying it or you can do
something about it i was like
i don't know he's like well it's up to
you but
it's you know you could do something
about it you could just let him keep
doing it
and i was like it does it was like
classic dad right
just so you know i'm not telling you
what to do but i'd be happy to sit in
the office
i'll keep the car running so
so i go in and i
walk down the hall and john i walk past
him he goes
hey [ __ ] oh my gosh there's like always
and you know i just turn around i walk
right up to him
and i i just [ __ ] hit him [ __ ]
i hit him and he popped back and he
didn't say anything
i think he was more stunned than
anything he's just shocked he just stood
there
and i i stared at him and thinking okay
he's gonna he didn't do anything
and i just walked to my locker and i
told my dad i was like yeah i just hit
him he goes what'd he do i go
i didn't do anything he just stood there
he goes he goes that's what most of them
will do you just got to hit them back
and most of them are scared that you
even did something i was like okay
so that was always kind of like
the way of operating not only in that
moment but i've learned early on that if
you're going to engage
you know just hit them first i don't
like to do this like shoving [ __ ] and
you you got a [ __ ] problem it's just
like there's this great movie open range
with kevin costner and robert duvall
and something happened to one of kevin
koster's friends and
and no i think it i think it's wyatt
earp i i love
kevin costner in western and it was
wyatt earp and he walks up to the
to the gang they're all talking [ __ ]
right and
kevin costner doesn't say [ __ ] he just
he's just walking right up he walks
right up to this guy
and the guy's mouthing off to him and
he's giving him [ __ ] as he's as he's
closing in
kevin costner as he's getting close
within like five years he goes are you
the one that shot my friend
and that guy goes yeah and he and he
just walks up bang and he just shot him
right in the [ __ ] face i was like
i never seen that in western but that's
the way to operate that's it someone's
talking [ __ ] say you know shit's gonna
go you just walk up
handle it yeah you don't need to be chit
chatting about this [ __ ] we know
everything we need to know yeah but
you know what's funny i'm thinking about
this over this is where my mind's going
the word [ __ ] yeah why are we still
allowed to use that when we refer
to armor why are we allowed to say yeah
why
whole speaking span there's a go i was
just about to say is there any other
racial
or racist term that's used could you
imagine there
if you could drop an m-bomb and
something like that he meant that like
well there was a college professor that
got that
lost his job because what he can spend
you're right when i was in china for the
even think of that another one's using
it anyways
so so
i was in beijing for the olympics in
2008 and i was walking through
beijing just as normal taurus does and i
kept hearing this word over and over and
over again
and it was uh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] and that is in in
uh china that's basically like you know
when you pick up your phone and somebody
calls you like hey where's your keys
um uh my keys are right over here like
that's almost like you're saying uh um
uh wow so so it's kind of like this uh
like hold over until you
catch your thought right so i was here
to constantly
and i understood how much of part of the
culture
it's just language right and this
college professor in california lost his
job because he was
he was defining the word for a class
and i think that's to the extent that
things are
especially in such a progressive state
as california where you can't even
define a word that could be offensive to
somebody where you're just
you're not you're taking out of context
yeah i'm educating you
exactly yeah and i think that's that's a
dangerous
slope
but it is crazy right to think that you
can't say certain words and look
i think it is as much as i
you know you see the violence and
everything that happened at the capitol
building
unfold and i as an american don't agree
with that
i don't agree with rioting at the
capitol building i don't agree with
rioting
in the streets and small businesses and
all that other stuff um but i do think
it is destructive
when you tell a sect of the population
you're allowed to communicate your
thoughts
and um opinions but you are not
and for you know uh big tech companies
to come in
and you know like twitter says you can't
say this stuff on a platform on other
platforms develop
for people that want to have that
opinion and voice
um and then and then big tech companies
come in and say
oh you left twitter you could but now
we're gonna shut that down now too it's
just like
i think that's a dangerous area and i
think any standard comedian whether you
disagree or agree
with with what is being said
i think you should still agree with the
fact that everybody in this country has
the right
to express their opinion um especially
in comedy and i understand people say
words hurt
but paul mccartney is never going to
tell insane class posse that's not music
no like we should all be able to still
be able to
you know there's an audience for
everybody do you remember when growing
up i'm how old are you now
46. okay i've got one year on you yeah
it was sticks and stones
they break my bones but names will never
hurt your words will never hurt
i mean that was what you it was like a
nursery rhyme that you just put in your
kids like it's words
it's names like you know i get racism is
complete
yeah yeah if you know like your dad said
is that
well he's gonna keep saying it until you
[ __ ] make sure he doesn't say it
anymore yeah
i really ended up being friends with the
kids and i i ended up being friends with
him and his family i'd go over and have
dinner with them and stuff
i remember one time i was on a swing did
you ever tell them
no no did your dad ever bust his balls
when he came over no no no oh
i would yeah
[Laughter]
my dad was cool my dad i mean he is cool
he he told me i remember one time i was
trying to swing at the playground and
the kids were making fun of me you can't
swing
and i told my dad i'm like yeah they
make fun of me i can't swing he's like
well can you
i was like no he's like well then there
you go
and that was it i was like oh i gotta
work harder swinging yeah it's like he
wasn't there to coddle me or anything
like that so
yeah he's definitely a you know an older
generation
which i i respect well i ask we've
talked about a lot i ask all my first
time guests advice they would give to
their 16 year old self so looking back
through some of the things we've talked
yeah about today what advice would you
give to 16 year old you
oh [ __ ] it's so funny because this
this was actually sent to me by a woman
that did
an article um
on me uh in high school oh yeah so if
you want to
hold that up to one of your cameras
that's me my senior class picture
of nowhere look at eight is it you a 17
or 18 here
i'm 17 right there and do you know how
bad this picture was
you don't look anything like jackie chan
bro
[Laughter]
there's so many zits in the actual
picture
my parents didn't order my senior class
picture
is that right because it was so bad they
didn't want to they didn't want it
they didn't they didn't they never
ordered it so you go into like
your your parents house there's always
the picture about the fireplace
because there were so many zits on my
face it was so embarrassing um
but if i was to tell a 17 year old 16 16
16 year old steve burn anything and be
like
hang tight you still have two years
until your first kiss
was it 18 i was 18. yeah i graduated
high school until i had my first kiss
but um i would tell myself
all the things you're getting made fun
of when you're 16
15 14 everything you've experienced that
will end up being your superpower
when you get older yeah no that's great
all those things that
that that you don't even accept right
now you're going to embrace those things
in your 20.
those are the things are going to make
you different and those things that
that are going to make you special it's
not a tattoo it's everything in here and
all that [ __ ] that you got made fun of
it's gonna make you a better person
so i think that's probably what i tell
myself dude that's great that is really
great i've been i haven't heard that one
yet
yeah because i'm not a [ __ ] heck like
all these other ones
one more time again promote everything
please uh the city of pittsburgh
it's uh the steelers it's the city of
champions
not this year no not this year not this
year but much respect to the ravens
because you brought a bona fide
[ __ ] rivalry back to the steelers
that is true and it is we have a great
one it makes the best
rivalry in sports in sports people like
i know
packers bears whatever that those are
historic
the best rivalry statistically are our
two teams
every time we match up every time to
violence
cheers to violence on the field
it makes me miss drinking yeah i wish i
could have some whiskey right now
like the coffee store patio or something
with with everybody
you have a joint outside man yeah no i
don't i don't smoke
whiskey's my thing but but i i think i'd
be remiss if
if on behalf of both of us we didn't we
didn't say we miss uh our good friend
jeff scott
yeah i can't even that was
it just feels like 2020 is continuing it
doesn't feel like it's ended
it just feels like it just carried right
over and that was
yeah i was texting with uh emily and and
i know brian scalero i was talking with
him he just had him on i was watching
that
and yeah seemed totally healthy i mean
just
and a cleveland boy yeah and he'd be
somebody that i would uh
i would love to sit and talk with before
and after my sets while he got high
and then half the time i'm on stage
doing my [ __ ] set i'm wondering if
jeff scott is going to come back and
play me off this is going to be a 20
minute set and then eliza is going to be
pissed at me because i ran the lights
like yeah [ __ ] he's getting i
don't [ __ ] yell at me talk to jeff
scott
well thank you brother thank you for
coming on uh ryan sickler
on all social media ryan sickler.com and
as always we'll talk to you all
next week
[Music]
you